[Music]
as I'm taping this right now there is a
massive wildfire burning about 70 miles
north of here in Ventura County as of
just a couple minutes ago it had already
burned over 50 thousand acres and over
30,000 homes have been evacuated I'm
sure by the time you see this those
numbers are gonna go up significantly
here in Los Angeles there's soot flying
around all over the place and there's a
dark gray haze and deep smell of smoke I
just walked my dog for literally two
minutes two minutes and not only
couldn't I see all the way down to the
end of the block because of the smoke
but my clothes absolutely stink right
now we just finished up our interview
for this week with Jessica Flanagan from
the University of Richmond and although
we never edit for content on this show
we actually are probably going to edit
out a couple coughs and hacks as the air
quality in the studio is pretty bad
right now
ironically our interview had a lot to do
with Public Health so stay tuned for
that I don't mention any of this for
pity for me dealing with some soot and
some smoke today as much as how things
can be put into perspective pretty
quickly of course a quick perusal of
Twitter allowed me to see people saying
California's burning because of its
leftist sins and others saying it's
burning because of global warming and
lack of regulation yes even natural
disasters are political these days as
we're in the midst of the holiday season
perhaps let's try to be a little less
political as we run out 2017 the spirit
of the season is about joy and giving
not fighting and bickering yet
unfortunately it seems we do the latter
too a lot more often than the former to
these days the people being affected far
worse than me by these fires are on the
left and on the right they're pro-choice
and they're pro-life they're black and
they're white and they're Christian and
they're atheist it's not just good ideas
that can bring us together but also bad
events so let's not make them worse with
an extra helping of hate I'm gonna try
to be a little less partisan a little
more open and a little less political as
the year comes to an end I think I do a
pretty decent job of being fair and
open-minded in general but a touch more
of those traits never hurt especially
around holiday time politics is
important but it isn't more
port and then finding some room in your
life to be grateful to be decent and to
be tolerant my challenge if you're up
for it is to perhaps try being a little
more tolerant yourself in the spirit of
the season I know that your intellectual
opponents and sometimes even friends and
family members often won't make it easy
but I think it'll be worth the effort as
we wind down this crazy year whether we
like it or not we're in this thing
together and perhaps putting out some
brush fires now will spare us from some
major fires in the future
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today is an assistant professor of
philosophy politics economics and law at
the Jepson school of leadership studies
at the university of richmond jessica
flanagan welcome to the Rubin report hi
how are ya do it well yeah let's learn
some Liberty it's kind of funny we're
gonna talk about a whole slew of things
here but medical ethics are involved and
act them as we are taping this at this
very moment there is a massive wildfire
about 45 minutes from here the smoke and
soot outside right now that's even
seeping into the studio at the moment I
was just sneezing right before we
started I can feel it in my lungs are
you are you feeling it at all yeah no
it's pretty intense out there yeah you
were you were gonna walk here from the
hotel which is only about four blocks
away and you were like no yeah I bailed
so there's something about medical
ethics or something with smoke and fire
or as you said right before sorry maybe
that's more environmental ethics perhaps
yeah I don't know what it is out there
but yeah it's a lot it's alright alright
so we're gonna talk all sorts of things
but let's start with medical ethics we
talk a lot about health care in America
and there's this sort of endless crazy
debate about Obamacare and Trump care
and Olson single-payer and all the buzz
words and phrases what do you think
we're really missing when it comes to
the general health care debate or what
do you think of the tenor of the health
care debate in general I think a lot of
what people focus on in the health care
debate is with regards to access with
health insurance like how
insurance we have single-payer a
free-market healthcare and I think
that's an important debate and that's
been the focus of a lot of political
philosophy and a lot of political
conversation about health care but one
thing I think we overlooked our kind of
clinical ethics like the ethics of what
happens and within that clinical context
within the system setting aside who pays
for it how we pay for it
things like pharmaceutical regulation
drug policy public health issues so I
think that a lot of times people will
sort of think about public health more
in an instrumental way of like how do we
promote the public health like what's
going to save lives and balance in terms
of public health policy but not asking
the broader question of should we be
involved in thinking about public health
as the kind of thing that public
officials should be promoting so those
are some things I think are overlooked
so things like regulation public health
ethics criminal justice and at health
like how those two areas of policy
intersect and the clinical context
informed consent and self medication
things like that things that happen in
the doctor's office yeah so I want to
dive into - all of those things for sure
so in terms of just the the general idea
of healthcare are you for having the
government have people buy into the
exchanges and all that one thing to say
about the United States system is like
here's like a place for like everybody
can totally agree like this is not the
ideal system I think you might not a
good system yeah whatever your favorite
system is I think this is like like a
non-ideal non-ideal solution yeah it's
like very robustly bad is there a system
that you look at elsewhere and say
they're they're really doing it right I
mean not really I think that a lot of
other systems have advantages and
disadvantages that we could learn from I
think that it's sort of a weird
historical accident that we have this
crazy Rube Goldberg of the health care
we have here I think that Australia may
be on the right track and having like a
kind of basic minimum but then like
markets on top although I don't my
impression is that they don't really
do like drugs the way that I would like
with respect to allowing more price
competition in pharmaceuticals but I
kind of favor a more market-based
approach is my own view but again
because we have a global marketplace
like the markets themselves are like not
ever going to be necessarily what like
your ideal of a market would be for
health care um but so you the first
question you asked was like should the
government be requiring people to buy
health insurance yeah I don't think that
they should I think that how having
health insurance fits into you know a
person's values isn't really a choice
that a public officials like well-placed
to make for everybody it might be the
case that you know people don't benefit
dollar per dollar for health insurance
as much as they do for just having the
money and so I think like a good
benchmark for like is this a good policy
is would a person benefit more if you
just gave them the money instead of like
spending the money on them or requiring
them to spend the money on a certain
things from their own money on a certain
thing I also have written elsewhere
about so that's like about individual
mandates or individual requirements to
pay into health care systems
mmm in particular I've also written
elsewhere about like employer mandates
so should employers be required to pay
for health insurance if they're they
have more than 50 employees for the
employees I don't think so
where does the 50 number come from I
think that's just in the Affordable Care
Act it's like it was I don't know how it
being implemented now but it was about
the time that I wrote that paper about
it right so the implication being that
if you're if you're that big at that
point then it's something that the
government should handle know that then
they could mandate that employers
provide health insurance over 50 yeah
employers and I think one thing I think
is that freedom of contract is an
important freedom and I think that when
the government says oh you and I we
could negotiate a contract but the
contract has to contain certain terms
like a certain wage or a certain
provision of benefits I think that would
violate individual people's freedoms of
contract and so I think people should be
able to make
agreements under whatever terms they
want for the most part and so the
requirement that the government could
say like well you have to pay people in
health insurance and that bad
requirement would fall on people who are
employing people who are already
benefiting them much more than any other
random people in the community are
benefiting there these employees I think
that that would be a violation of
Fremont contract so yeah I'm sort of
against both yes I have my gets them
individual and employer based mandates
because I think that we should trust
people to decide what in the cotton and
their contracts are in their personal
spending choices are best for them yeah
so in a weird way as at least a one-time
Obama voter right you voted for Obama at
least one yeah yeah that sort of puts
you a little bit at odds with Obama care
though
or not a little bit that kind of really
puts you at odds with Obama care
ya know yeah so is that something you
really struggled with as you were voting
for him cuz right I mean that's really
the landmark piece of legislation right
I mean that's that's the thing that
he'll most likely be remembered for the
most yeah I think you know why do people
vote the way they do I mean a lot of
reasons but no I disagree with the
Affordable Care Act right yeah so did
you make any sense of when they were
trying to pass Trump care or whatever
his version of did you know or now even
they're scaling back little bits of it
or they're defunding parts of it it's
hard to pay attention or not even pay
attention it's hard to track actually
what the real world resolution is with
this stuff did did you see any goodness
in any of that that they were scaling
back some of it I mean who's changing
like every week it wasn't hard to even
keep up when that was that health care
debate was happening my impression was
that it was worse for people in that it
like didn't really solve the fundamental
objections people had to the Affordable
Care Act but then it created other
problems in the markets and the
exchanges but so what so what are you
doing cases of if you let it completely
free market and you didn't have
companies have to do anything under 50
over 50 whatever it is what do you do
for all the people that will just be
left behind
all the people that were just going
we're either just flat-out dying because
they weren't seeing a doctor or the
people that were then going to emergency
rooms which we know the costs of doing
that are actually way higher than if
they had had you know care when when
they should have what's the free-market
sort of answer to that yeah it depends
on whether or not so oftentimes people
will say health care is a right and what
do you mean by that Bernie says another
thing right I believe it what do you
mean by right so you might think that a
right is always enforceable if somebody
has a right to something then they have
right against other people to provide it
to be clear you don't think it's a right
I don't think right well I just think it
depends on what you mean by right right
but I mean I don't
all right I mean we have the right to
life liberty the pursuit of happiness
really the right the Bill of Rights yeah
I don't think there's anything in there
that says you have the right to health
care certainly not an enforceable right
right that other people provide you with
it I'm skeptical of that claim and so
what would it mean for there to be an
enforceable right to health care what
would it mean for their beauty right
that you had to claim that another
person provide it with you well it means
that you could use the enforcement power
of the state public officials could use
their enforcement power to compel other
people to provide their compete reott
swith health care and then my question
about that is why health care like why
is the thing that people are required to
be providing their compatriots health
care and not something like a basic
income which I do support income or or
they could kind of decide how to
allocate their resources themselves in
accordance with our own value or
providing people with something like a
basic standard of well-being and then
like if you one until I provide people
with a you know set standard of
well-being a set of opportunities and
health outcomes it's not clear that like
having them buy health insurance or have
health insurance would be the thing that
would promote that mmm-hmm so it does
not even seem like health care is there
it's like health insurance is the thing
that people are saying is their right
and so in order to establish that
there's an enforceable right for the
public officials to compel people to
fellow citizens to provide other people
with health insurance it would have to
be that health insurance in particular
was this thing that was so important
like human autonomy flourishing and
well-being that it could warrant like
coercively you compelling people to
provide it now once we have that as our
bar like it was like this is the bar
like I think a lot of other things we
clear such a bar before health insurance
would I think it look like why for
example well a basic income for one I
think that like having some kind of
floor of material security we pry it so
basically once you've said this is a
right that we should have there's a
whole bunch of other things that using
that standard you think would be on the
list before health insurance right and
so if you think that there's an
enforceable right that people should
have health care you'd have to explain
in virtue of what do other people make
themselves liable to be coerced by the
government in order to provide their
fellow citizens with that right mm-hmm
in virtue of what value and whatever
value that is I would worry but there's
like a lot of other stuff we do putting
on the list before health insurance yeah
if they're also like a part of it that
it almost hardly sets people up against
each other in a weird way so if you take
good care of yourself and you exercise
and you eat right and you pay into the
system and you're healthy but then you
know you go to the supermarket and you
see someone buying a ton of soda and
eating horrible foods that's overweight
never exercising but you know that
they're going to be more of a strain on
the system than you and you're basically
paying for them you know and so it's
sort of it would make you sort of almost
angry at people for not taking care of
themselves because they there then
expending the resources that you're
putting into the system because you're
living better so to speak I do think
that there is sort of a link between
support for like kind of spreading
across the house of health care and
support for public health paternalism I
think that and I think that is the link
which is that people think that if
they're paying taxes to support programs
that are going to provide health care
for people that that gives them and
or a stake in the health of other people
right but then think it through so say
that you do think that health care or
health insurance is an enforceable right
then everybody has a right to it no
matter what
mm-hmm then people don't make themselves
preemptively liable to have their other
liberties limited on the grounds that in
virtue of their choices or permissible
choices they're gonna make it more
expensive to enforce those rights so by
that I just mean like say that you're a
person that just wants to eat like
Doritos and coca-cola all day which is
delicious
why do you college I'd be sympathetic I
do that you know and then people say
well like no you can't just do that or
you can't smoke cigarettes because if
you do then we're all gonna have to pay
for it well then you might say like oh
wait a minute
like who cares like you have an
obligation in virtue of my enforceable
right to pay for it anyhow and so like
you don't get to tell me what to do just
because subsequently you're going to
have to give me what I'm owed which is
high health care if you owe me $50 and
you don't like how I'm gonna spend the
$50 you don't get to write you know tell
me to change my behavior before you give
me the $50 I just think it could it's
not an enforceable concept but it's just
I think it would just cause resentment I
think in general like if you're just
like I don't I don't expend a lot from
the system I don't take a lot from the
system and here are other people that do
it's just sort of human nature I think
to resent like yeah just sort of resent
it yeah yeah yeah maybe I mean I don't
think that they should if they really
think that they have a duty to provide
it right well I don't know that people
really think it through all the way and
maybe a certain amount of people don't
think they have a duty to provide yeah
don't think I would do provide it their
issue isn't with the people eating
Doritos and smoking cigarettes their
issue is with being forced to provide at
other people with health insurances you
know a different gripe so either way you
don't have any kind of grounds to
present or to want to limit the freedom
of the people who just want to smoke
cigarettes named Doritos because like
which I feel like I'm like hating under
readers it's not maybe it's about to
read
everybody loves the Cool Ranch yeah
right but so I feel like you know if
you're a person who thinks health care
is a right then you have no grounds to
want to limit the choices to those
people because you buy your own lights
think that you have a duty to provide
them a health care whatever their choice
is all right and if you're you know
irritated by people making public you
know making choices that could be
prevented with public health paternalism
that you disapprove of on the grounds
that you don't want to pay for their
health insurance then what's doing the
work is really just that you don't want
to pay for their health insurance and so
then you also don't have any real beef
with people making bad health decisions
right and so either side I don't think
should support public health paternalism
interesting you know you mentioned
cigarettes a couple times it's funny
because literally my chest is tight
right now I don't smoke cigarettes but
from the smoke outside like I can feel
it at this moment
and I always think the cigarette thing
is kind of interesting because I used to
live in New York City and I'm pretty
sure cigarettes for something like 12 or
15 dollars a pack like taxed beyond
imagination which I always thought was
was an odd thing because it's like
you're taking people with this vice and
then you know and an addiction a true
addiction to tobacco and all the other
stuff that's in there and then you're
you're making all of this extra money
off it that the government then needs to
do whatever it's doing so it's like a
doubly abusive thing in a way not that
you should just be giving cigarette
cigarettes away for free but taxing
these vices these addictive vices you're
just taking more money from those people
and putting it now you're going to need
the government never wants less money so
it's never going to be like all right
we're gonna lose tax that lower or we're
gonna stop spending there is some
evidence that cigarette taxes do reduce
smoking which makes sense unless you
think that cigarette is like this
cigarettes are sort of this like
uncontrollable compulsion that people
have which would be interesting then
that if you increase the price of it by
a dollar then people stop doing it right
you're saying to poor people then it's
probably poor people that men can't
afford it so then it's like well poor
people shouldn't be allowed to smoke
cigarettes which I think some people
would have that is the way it goes down
I don't know but I do think that sin
taxes in general are like cigarette
taxes taxes on things that the
government doesn't want people to do
like soda taxes are another example they
are regressive
for sure I mean just because you know
the marginal value of that dollar is
going to be disproportionately the
marginal impact of being taxed an
additional dollar will be
disproportionately harmful to people who
have less money and so we have these
regressive public health taxes that are
going to disproportionately burden the
economically worse off and I also think
that they're very expressively harmful
because they express disapproval of
certain people's choices on behalf of
the government which it's not morally
wrong to smoke cigarettes it's not
morally wrong to drink soda and so I
don't think that the government should
be expressing disapproval or limiting
people's rights to make choices that are
permissible right again I think there's
some sort of argument that says if the
government is gonna give health
insurance to everyone that maybe then at
the same time the government has a right
to tell you you should I don't agree
with this but I can see the argument
though that all right the government's
gonna give other jurors everyone well
then why can't the government say you
know it and you can't smoke cigarettes
and you can't drink soda with high
fructose corn syrup because we know it's
going to give you diabetes which is also
going to be a strain on the system again
I don't yeah I agree with that but I can
understand that line of thinking yeah if
that were the argument then I would
think that then you should let people
opt out so it'd be like hey free health
insurance in exchange for not smoking or
drinking soda or exchange for exercising
or something I don't think people would
be on board with that though I don't
think that they would like it if there
was a policy of making the provision of
public services conditional on people
behaving right you'd have a black market
basically of soda you know people would
be secretly smuggling so I mean what I
was saying was like you know maybe if
people if taxpayers like oh we don't
want to pay for people's health
insurances are gonna make these bad
choices that still doesn't justify
banning the bad choices because you
could just say if you want to get you
know publicly subsidized health
insurance then you can't make these bad
choices then you can't smoke or then you
can't drink soda I don't think people
would accept that I don't think people
would say that that was their ideal of a
public provide a health insurance system
where it's like you know if you wanna
where people would have to voluntarily
limit their liberty in order to have
access to it yeah I don't think that
most people who support
like Medicaid for all would support a
system where Medicaid for all but people
can opt out of it in exchange for the
right to smoke cigarettes right it's
interesting because I would always veer
on more choice and yet we find ourselves
at a place where it's like well people
are gonna do bad things and you're just
gonna sort of have to pay for it if we
have less choice it's just that it is
great so go through that argument again
that if you that if you have less choice
meaning the government is going to make
you have health insurance or whatever it
is that people are going to do bad
things and you're gonna sort of have to
subsidize it it's just right I mean yeah
be for banning it yeah yeah it's an
interesting thing I mean in the
cigarette one I think it's particularly
interesting because the government
you're saying here's this is something
bad we all agree this is bad the
government is now gonna make a lot of
money off something bad and it wants
money so it almost wants you to smoke
cigarettes you know yeah I don't know
that the government wants people but
they want that money and they know it's
a way to make money right I don't know
that they want I don't think they're
sitting in a thing going we got to get
more people smoking cigarettes yeah when
they look at the numbers and they're
like wow look at all this money we took
in from cigarettes I think they probably
view that as a good they want more money
but I think at the same time public
officials are definitely invested in
reducing long term health care cost and
reducing rates of smoking and so I mean
it's hard to like I think people often
use this idea where they're like the
government does this so like the
government does that but like there's
not one thing that like is like the
government right it's just public
officials with different kind of
motivations and so but I don't think
that many public officials are motivated
of like oh yeah let's raise money
through cigarette taxes I think that the
primary motivation of people who pass
the Grant taxes is to deter people from
smoking right but I don't think that
that's I don't even think that's a good
motivation I don't know which the
primary motivator
it's bad enough of it they're just like
oh we want to like cast judgment on
people's permissible choices in order to
discourage it like I think that that's
like I mean I think that's sinister
enough yeah if you want a reason to
oppose the cigarette taxes yeah all
right well I think we hit the basics of
sort of the main public policy
stuff that I wanted to get to let's talk
a little bit about medical ethics
sorry in general define medical ethics
what people ought to do in healthcare
and medical contexts and you want people
to have more choices than they currently
have that's right yeah so I wrote a book
Parma cycle freedom yeah christmas is
coming makes it will have a link in the
description and the argument for the
book is that the same reasons in favor
of informed consent which is a core
principle of medical ethics are also
reasons in favor of rights of self
medication yeah way let's do let's
define some of the terms so informed
consent is is that physicians are not
entitled to make medical decisions on
behalf of their patients as long as
their patient is competent and patients
have rights against being coerced into
making particular medical decisions
medically competent patients are not
children and that it's also
impermissible for physicians or anyone
else to deceptively mislead or withhold
information from a patient in order to
get them to make a medically advisable
decision how do you actually figure out
what informed means what the word in
four means I mean when I've been to
hospitals with grandparents sort of at
the end of life and when they're trying
to do the last few things that they can
do and they say well we can do this or
that or you know all these different
things they're explaining it usually to
you but you don't really feel informed
like you you really don't know unless
you're a doctor yourself so how do you
actually define what informed really
means is that the patient should be
informed up to this kind of reasonable
patient standards so like what a
reasonable person would deem relevant to
the content of their decision and so
that includes both information about the
risks and benefits of particular
treatment but also information about
treatment alternatives and also
information about the risks and benefits
of having no treatment of declining
treatment entirely so that's the sort of
broad standard of what level of
information is required for a patient to
have access to some patients might want
to not know certain information this is
becoming increasingly an issue with
things like information about genetic
risk factors for example and so then
patients should have the right to also
kind of consent
to the uncertainty perhaps and so say
like well we could disclose genetic risk
factors from this analysis unless you
don't want to know I think so in effect
you then would be opting out and then
you're sort of waiving any of your legal
rights I assume after I don't know what
the legal context is but I think morally
patients should be entitled to
essentially exercise as much control
over the amount of information they want
with respect to their medical choices
and also to have unrestricted access to
whatever information they would deem
relevant to their medical choices but
the doctors should be on the hook to
provide patients in the context of
medical tests decision with whatever
information a reasonable patient would
want to know about the risks and
benefits of treatment driven
alternatives and no information no
treatment right but in it so in effect
though you you as a patient could say to
your doctor there are things that I will
not want to know and your doctor yeah my
own view is that that's true that lay
patients should be able to opt out of
knowing although they will have to agree
an example of something like that so I
think that the primary example where
this is an issue is with testing for
genetic risks so if physicians know that
a person has a late-in-life risk of a
certain disease should the physician be
required to disclose it to the patient
and I think that the physician should be
required to disclose that the test might
turn up certain diseases and then ask
the patient if they want to know because
some people might prefer to live in
ignorance of that type of knowledge
that's controversial a matter of ethics
whether or not patients should have a
right to know
but informed consent is less
controversial outside of those Martin
those are kind of marginal cases right
it's like outside of those more marginal
cases we're all familiar today with what
informed consent requires so you go to
the doctor you say treatment a treatment
B what are the risks and benefits of the
two and the main idea of informed
consent is that you are the author of
your own medical choices you're the
person that's in the driver's seat not
the doctor and so the doctor can't trick
you mislead you withhold information or
coerce you in order to get you to make a
decision that the doctor thinks is
medically advisable it didn't always
used to be this way so
the emergence of informed consent
happened in the 20th century before then
physicians were very paternalistic
towards people and even well into the
20th century so there was a survey done
in the late 60s of oncologist about
people who are diagnosed with cancer
whether or not they always accurately
revealed the diagnosis 90% of con
colleges said that they did not always
accurately reveal cancer diagnosis to
their cancer patients meaning that they
were no they would withhold a diagnosis
from patients paternalistically for fear
that the diagnosis would be harmful to
the patient's if they knew it
sometimes even substituting in an
alternative diagnosis and it was 1968
1968 I think the study was so that a
little further what would be the
legitimate if you were an oncologist and
you knew that one of your patients had
cancer what would be the argument for at
the time they thought that there was at
least in some cases the in colleges were
those would withhold or mislead patients
about their diagnosis on the grounds
that they thought that the information
about the diagnosis would be harmful to
patients wow I mean that's incredible
yeah but yeah now we think that that
sounds bananas that was just very recent
so informed consent has only robustly
been with us for the past 50 years or so
in this way and now it's baked in we all
understand like yes it is wrong for
doctors to mislead people or to lie to
people about their diagnosis it's wrong
for doctors to coerce people into
accepting surgery so the first informed
consent case was in 1912 1913 and it was
a case where doctors performed a
hysterectomy on a woman without her
consent
she actually explicitly said that she
did not consent to surgery then she was
being examined under ether and the
doctors removed her organs that doesn't
happen yeah anymore when it does it's
like a big deal like it's not a battery
it's a form of assault yeah
so we now think about patient choice and
people's control over their health in a
much more respectful way I think that's
been like a shine of moral progress like
I believe in moral progress in the
worlds you know capable of morally
improving I think
one example at the same time however
across the 20th century patients slowly
lost rates of self-medication
so while over the course of the 20th
century patients were gaining the
authority in the doctor's office to make
medical decisions for themselves they
were losing that authority at the
pharmacist and so the book is about why
the same reasons that give patients the
authority to make medical decisions
about their own bodies in the clinical
contacts are also reasons in favor of
giving people rides of self medication
in the marketplace and in the
pharmaceutical so how did we lose
control of some of that related to the
pharmaceuticals well there were a series
of drug disasters the first elixir
sulphate of IED in the 1930s and then
that the lid of my disasters in the
1960s which the United States avoided
because of a regulator at the FDA who
was very cautious in approving the drug
application for thalidomide those drug
disasters led and both health and at
both times for public outcry for
increased pharmaceutical regulation
first can you tell me a little bit more
about what the the drug actually was
yeah so looks are still fit amide um
sorry there's no fires outside I mean
they're really I'm feeling it right now
while we're doing this a little bit of
mine was essentially an anti in fact in
that was diluted with something like
antifreeze and it was distributed in the
1930s and when it was this drug was
diluted in this kind of anti freeze like
substance diethylene glycol a lot of
people mostly children died from taking
it and after the children died from
taking it there was a lot of media
coverage the drug was recalled there
were lawsuits but there wasn't really
much of a legal basis for punishing the
people besides the fact that it was
mislabeled mm-hmm
and so there was public outcry against
the fact that this very dangerous
medicine was being distributed to people
and they didn't have an opportunity to
consent the initial drug regulations
that passed authorizing the FDA
stipulated that it was only intended to
make self medication say
for a more effective so in the 1900s
rates of self-medication were widely
affirmed people believed in rights of
self-medication and the initial
regulations that were passed were just
supposed to be like labeling
requirements making it so people could
be informed what they're taking
but the approval process quickly evolved
into a safety standard requiring pre
market safety testing in order to
establish that people knew what they
were getting when they're taking a drug
by the 1960s when the thalidomide
disaster happened which was a drug that
was used by pregnant women to treat
morning sickness and then it caused
miscarriages and then some children to
be born without limbs it mostly hit in
Europe and we avoided it because of our
drug approval process in the United
States by this time the FDA became a
kind of model for the world about drug
regulation and that still is true today
so a lot of other countries kind of
mirror their regulatory approach off of
the FDA and United States avoided it
because of regulatory caution with
respect to a new drug application but
seeing the pictures of the infants that
were born without limbs from lid amide
there was once again a great deal of
public support in the FDA past the
Congress authorized the FDA to enforce
efficacy testing requirements as well so
now in order for a drug to be brought to
market it needs to be shown that it is
both safe and effective before being
brought to market that sounds like a
good idea
road to hell is paved with good intent
in you but now say that the FDA approves
the drug and it says you know we
fast-tracked this drug it got approved
very quickly we approved it you know
from basic research to approval five
years so it should be very very fast and
now we expect it to save 10,000 lives a
year the way that you should perhaps
hear that is that tens of thousands of
lives were lost during every year that
approval for the drug is withheld people
see the children who died during the
elixir cyl fit of my disaster that would
have made babies but people don't see
the people who look like they were dying
of their diseases but they were actually
dying because of regulatory caution
because they couldn't get access to
drugs that could potentially help yeah
you don't it doesn't if not as vivid to
us when people die for a lack of access
to drugs mm-hmm but
it really is the case that though it
looks like their diseases are what's
calling them was actually telling them
is the lack of access yeah so this is
kind of a tough place for someone with
certain libertarian leanings like
yourself to be in right because you kind
of you're acknowledging the FDA did some
good work in the first place here but
then that right like right I mean I
think you are I don't wanna put words in
your mouth but you're acknowledging that
by having this regulation at first it
stopped it from coming to the United
States correct well I mean I don't even
think that necessarily because that the
approval process for the drug wouldn't
have even been for pregnant women most
pregnant women use drugs off-label I
think that people saw it as a win for
the FDA because the FDA didn't approve
the new drug application and so the
United States largely avoided the crisis
but I don't think that the current
system would have prevented a crisis
like the lid imide and the United States
because very few drugs are approved for
use in pregnant women and so it's like
sort of this weird historic I don't know
that we should credit the FDA in this
way for like intentionally preventing
that now so like when you're like oh you
credit the FDA with certain things I do
think one thing the FDA does that is
good is that it enables inform patient
choice it certifies drugs so my view is
like if you like the FDA which I know a
lot of people do it's one of the most
popular regulatory agencies fine let it
do everything it does now let it certify
drugs like the Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval I also think there should be
other certification C's for drugs it's
like when you go to Whole Foods and
there's like 15 different certifications
on all of your different you got a lot
of things on those boxes yeah well you
know let any drug have all sorts of
certifications but including as we have
with food like USDA like let them
certify drugs what I object to is the
FDA prohibiting drugs which they have
been doing for a long time and so what
you would holding access to drugs I
think violates people's rights it's a
violation of the rights to make
decisions about their own bodies yeah
are there any particular drugs at the
moment that they're withholding that you
think are real game changers I mean it's
always hard to know I mean that's the
reason that they do withhold it is
because there is high uncertainty
for unapproved drugs there's also high
uncertainty for approved drugs mm-hmm
but yeah I wanted to ask you about that
actually because everyone knows I mean
it's it's a joke that everybody makes
you turn on the TV you watch any
commercial half the commercials these
days or for prescription drugs they tell
you a little something good about it at
the beginning where the guys running in
the field and everybody's happy and he's
on a mountain and then the
three-quarters of the commercial really
are about the diarrhea and upset stomach
and thoughts of suicide and restless leg
syndrome and blindness and a kajillion
other things so something seems wrong
with the way we are medicating ourselves
or the way that these things get passed
it's almost as if our bodies are telling
us not to be on half of this stuff not
to say I have friends that are on
different things and I had a friend that
was really helped by lithium and a bunch
of other things but that there's some
odd thing that we're doing with
overmedicating or that that we push this
stuff on ourselves constantly whether or
not a person should use any kind of a
drug is a decision that should just be
made in terms of the risk-benefit
calculus for their own life as a whole
and who's the expert about your life as
a whole you are and so what happens with
the FDA is that they impose these broad
based judgments that apply to everybody
when they prohibit a drug or withhold
access to a drug before approval that
say that the drug is unacceptably risky
and then when they approve a drug they
say this junk was approved because the
risks are acceptable in light of the
benefits now that's a lot of scientific
judgment that's not a judgment that the
FDA is well-placed to make whether or
not something's acceptable risky is a
normative judgment it's a judgment what
you should do with your own life in your
own body so medical experts doctors
pharmaceutical regulators public
officials are not experts about whether
or not something's acceptable rescue the
person who's an expert about whether
it's acceptability rescue the patient
now you seem to be saying like well
patients are taking too many risks like
they're using too many drugs well it
seems like we're inundated with so much
of this that everyone I mean I think
we're the most over medicated country in
the world I'm not you can correct me if
I'm wrong but I think it's something
like I don't think isn't it illegal for
some of these commercials to be on all
the time in Europe I'm pretty sure they
have laws against some of this stuff and
yet for us we're slammed with it
constantly and I think that that causes
your ability
but that's bad that there's so much
pharmaceutical advertising I'm not for
over-regulation so this is one of the
places where it's it's a struggle right
like I'm trying to be intellectually
honest here I'm not for over-regulating
these things and I'm always for more
choice so I understand the argument but
the general allow me but the general the
general idea that were slammed with so
much of us that it makes your ability to
make a clear minded choice more
difficult and we're going to talk about
critical thinking a little more at the
end because I think that well I'm in
favor of direct-to-consumer drug
marketing which the United States is one
of only a few countries that allow it
and I think that's good I think that's
like part of our sort of strong
commitment to freedom of speech that we
do include commercial speech to an
extent within that and I think that if
the government were to say no
pharmaceutical advertising so that would
be a content-based restriction against
speech that advocates in favor of lawful
conduct on the grounds that the
government doesn't agree with the
message yeah so I'm not worried about
that so I'm not against it I just think
our ability I don't know what the answer
is I'm just saying that our ability to
make informed choices about the drugs
that they're pushing us pushing on us
all the time seems to be very slippery
maybe we have that slippery ability
because we haven't been given the
autonomy to make decisions about our own
health maybe it's a kind of learned
helplessness from the fact that
currently you know people aren't aren't
authorized to make choices about their
own health so we have a prescription
requirement where you have to go to a
doctor and get the prescription maybe
people offload it to physicians and then
they accept more risk than they
otherwise would of because they think
well if a doctor would have prescribed
it then it's fine
and then the physicians have this other
way of looking at were like well if the
patient wants to take it like the risk
is on her and it could lead to more
risky decision making there's some
evidence from an economist from the 70s
who did research on this and peltzman
that prescription requirements actually
induced more risky decision making and
result in higher rates of accidental
drug poisonings because of this sort of
offloading effect where people think
that if a doctor told you it was okay to
take it that it's okay to take it so
that that's really interesting to me the
doctor right cuz they're like I the
doctor said it's okay so I'm gonna go
ahead and do it I don't even have to
listen to the people telling me that I'm
gonna diarrhea and thoughts of suicide
and all the rest of it where people are
yeah they take less they're less
cautious because they feel like their
decisions are authorized by first the
FDA the FDA approved it's an FDA
approved drug and by their doctors and
so they're more likely to take on risks
associated with you yeah so in an odd
way by removing some of these
restrictions it would actually
strengthen the doctor you think because
the person would be on the person yeah
to then take the responsibility for
themselves
I mean I've talked to some doctors about
this and they kind of like you might
think the doctors be like oh no we need
to keep prescription requirements but
they think right now you know look maybe
I could focus more on patient care you
know maybe we could you know focus more
on really having a conversation with
patients who want advice from a doctor
I'm not saying people shouldn't talk to
their doctors before making decisions
about which drugs to use I'm saying that
after they talk to their doctors the
decision should be in their hands and
that if they don't want to talk to a
doctor that's also their decision yeah
well you're also saying actually listen
when they list all of those side effects
yes I think that like you don't even
listen to that part you know and it's
why their marketing is so good all these
people are having a great time while
they're on Valtrex
you know what I mean and then you find
out what what all the side effects are
but you don't really oh well that won't
happen to me you know yeah I think that
you know patients should have the
autonomy to take responsibility for
their health have the authority to make
decisions about themselves and they
should take that seriously and they
should educate themselves and I think
that also people they should have access
to the relevant information I don't
think that you know I would favor you
know fair labeling requirements making
labels accessible for people to be able
to understand the risks and benefits of
the treatment but ultimately whether or
not a decisions acceptable risky whether
the risks outweigh the benefit no one
can make that decision for a patient
except for the patient yeah all right so
the through line here I think is more
choice fair to say I'm usually gonna be
in favor of more choice you're a
proponent of a
give altruism that sounds pretty good
what is effective so Peter Singer is
known for as a proponent of this and I
really admire Peter Singer and I think
that he's pretty persuasive on this
which is that though I'm not a
utilitarian and I don't agree with him
on a lot of other things I do think that
he's right that a lot of people who are
in rich countries have the capacity to
do an extraordinary amount of good by
donating to effective charities and that
is morally good if they do and so the
idea of effective altruism has two parts
the first is the ultrasone part that
comes first which is that it's morally
good to give it's morally good if you're
fortunate enough to be able to give and
what they recommend is 10 percent of
their of your income and then if you are
going to give once you're like onboard
with a view that it's morally good to
give to people to you know promote
well-being to promote people's health
well why why what where should we be
giving who should we give to and you
should give to the place where your
donation can do the most good
and so charities that I favor as an
effective ultra star the against malaria
foundation which mostly focuses on bed
nets mm-hmm bed net distribution and
give directly which is cash transfers to
poor families in Kenya and Uganda yeah
how do you figure out who's using the
money properly you know you always hear
a story every now and again of
nonprofits that you think you're giving
all this money to them and that they're
gonna you know clean water or whatever
it is but then later you find out like
80 percent of the money goes to
administrative costs or for them to
throw parties fundraisers to just get
more money to throw more parties or that
there's a great website give all calm
and give well has a team of researchers
which try to evaluate which charities
they think are going to be the most
effective and they recommend both give
directly on the against malaria
foundation one nice thing about give
directly is that cash transfers are
pretty easy to administer you can just
do it over mobile bank transfers and the
give directly team has a lot of people
who do really good follow
to see what the effects are so they can
see kind of the randomly assigned
villages to get the transfers and then
they can see the effect of having the
trans cash transfers as a poverty
anti-poverty intervention and it does
look like cash is like a very effective
anti-poverty intervention yeah is this
also in effect an argument for lowering
taxes in general that if people had more
money in their pocket perhaps 10% more
they could give 10% more to things that
they really cared about I think that
there are lots of good reasons to know
more taxes because I think that
currently like some of what the
government does with taxes is like not
great you know for example or very
against war I don't know that this is
the best argument for that but that
generally if you had more money in your
pocket you might be willing to give more
money to causes that you really care
about I think people should be willing
to give to causes that they care about
whatever their tax rate is um and I
think that people should care about
causes that do the most good dollar for
dollar yeah so you're also writing a
book on sex worked yeah it's a for and
against that wasn't a great segue yeah
yeah it's a foreign against book so it's
I'm the for decriminalization man I'm
writing with a co-author Laurie Watson
and she's against decriminalization yeah
so what's the argument against it at
this point I mean this is another place
that I go very much to the libertarian
side which is that if a woman a woman or
a man or whatever wants to take control
they're alive and be a prostitute or be
involved in sex work and it's an even
exchange and they're doing something for
money I have no problem with any of this
alright coolest person I need to come
there you go alright I'm with you on
this one so who am i arguing again yeah
there's a lot of people so some people
have a view of like sort of sexual
moralism
that you know there's certain norms that
should govern people's sexual choices
that's like a kind of more
traditionalist view I think that people
who hold that view are entitled to use
the government as a mean
to force everybody else to live in
accordance with it there's a feminist
argument people worry that having sex
work especially pornography but sex work
more generally will contribute to the
subordination and objectification of all
women by promoting sexist ideas of
female subordination or views of women
as objects but to be clear sex work
isn't only about women I mean their
planning involved detector
yeah but feminists focus on the
detrimental effects of the sex industry
for women as a whole right often their
arguments about occupational health and
safety related to the dangers associated
with the profession I don't think that
the profession is more dangerous than
being a commercial fisherman right and
aren't there studies that show that like
in in Amsterdam for example that you
know the women that are involved in sex
work are in unions and that they've been
able to bargain for a better health care
and things like that to be sure I think
about our ideal that's policy that I
favor is out of New Zealand where it's
just treated like all other kinds of
work but of course if you're concerned
about the risks the occupational health
and safety risks of sex work you should
be concerned by black markets as well
equally and black markets are more
dangerous so yeah there's a kind of kind
of traditionalist argument there's a
feminist argument there's a kind of a
labor argument a lot of people worry
that it's exploitative by that they mean
that if a person makes a decision
without having any acceptable
alternatives then though the decisions
not coerced it's not sufficiently
voluntary to merit respect mm-hmm I
think that that could apply to a lot of
work a lot of low-wage work especially
people will only choose to take those
jobs at the waves the daheia because
they lack acceptable alternatives I
think that we should therefore favor a
basic income so I do think that it's a
problem that people only choose certain
types of jobs or to work at all because
they lack acceptable alternatives and I
can talk more about life here at basic
income yeah but I also think that you
know if you don't favor of eights it can
come the voluntariness concerns don't
more in prohibition of sex work so if
the problem is that people who are
choosing to work in an industry only
choose because they have very few
options I don't think that an acceptable
solution to that is to just
straightforwardly prohibit the few
options that they do have this parallels
arguments in international Global
justice about sweatshops where it's like
like only choose to work in sweatshops
because they lack acceptable
alternatives I don't think the solution
would be to ban sweatshops or to even
enforce regulations that would lead
sweatshops to go to another place right
then half the people screaming about it
or holding you know have iPhones in
their pockets you know yeah right I mean
it's just a fact and I think that you
know when people are concerned about
these types of labor issues sex work
sweatshops
they are genuinely concerned for the
workers like I don't think that there's
a sort of bad faith there but I would
press those people to say like well what
is the alternative that goes along with
the bad I mean it's very easy to say I
don't approve of this circumstance but
I'm like what is your solution you know
I mean yeah like I favorite basic income
- but like filling a basic income I
don't think that further eliminating the
options of people who are already
suffering for a lack of options helps
them yeah so what would a basic income
look like to you I'm done correctly well
I don't take a big stand on like how
much it should be why do I favor a basic
income you might think like oh you're
libertarian broadly like why have the
government redistribution people's
income and that's what you were saying
like oh I'm against like a high tax like
I don't really have too much of opinion
on how high taxes would be necessarily
per se or like but I have more of a
penny on what they spend it on um public
officials spend it on yeah well I do
agree it's mostly about spending and
I've got to cut the spending down and
then the government would just need to
take less from you if it would stop
overreaching on what it thinks it's
supposed to do yeah and so like I'm
against a lot of what public officials
spend the money that they tax people on
but taxes in particular I'm a little bit
more ambivalent about I mean I don't
think given the political institutions
we have right now like no we shouldn't
we should oppose like kind of raising
money to go to war
that'd be bad because I think war is bad
but should we be in principle opposed to
taxes per se that's a little bit more
complicated so say that you're a broadly
kind of libertarian person a lot of
people will say that means that you know
nobody should violate another person's
natural rights but do people have
natural rights to not just their bodies
but external objects property out in the
world so one of my favorite philosophers
Michael humor kind of like an
anarcho-capitalist and he's like well at
least some stuff out in the world if you
build a hut like in the woods and like
you live there someone can't just like
roll in and like knock it down like you
have a natural property to that but some
other property rights are going to be
conventional some property rights are
gonna exceed whatever natural rights we
have so like money that's a good example
that's a very conventional system so now
you have a government and the government
says ok here's the property system that
we're going to enforce well one thing
that property system should do is it
should respect everybody's natural
property rights and natural rights to
their own bodies whatever that is mm-hmm
but then the government goes further and
they're like and also we're gonna
enforce all of these property
conventions and we're gonna use the
coercive power of this government that
nobody consented to like none of us
signed up right to enforce these kind of
property conventions and the thing about
these property conventions let's call
them capitalism is that they're gonna
make people generally better off but
they're gonna pick winners and losers
are gonna make some people worse off
some people really really badly off some
people fantastically well off so we have
the government that's enforcing you know
protections for people's natural rights
but also establishing these property
conventions how are the property
conventions enforced oh the property
conventions are enforced in part with
violence with coercion which is a threat
of violence against people's natural
rights their rights against being
threatened with violence and so I don't
think that you know I feel I don't favor
a basic income as in like I deal with
theoretic solution I think ideally
nobody would use violence against
anybody without their consent but given
that we have governments which are
using violence to enforce laws and
property conventions against everybody
without their consent a basic income is
a way of compensating people for that
injustice for the injustice of the
enforcement of a coercive property
system that forces conventions which the
enforcement of which requires violating
people's basic rights yeah it's
interesting because I've heard a couple
different libertarian arguments for
basic income and on its head if you were
just looking at it you would think that
just makes no sense and yet I I
completely understand what you're saying
there
what is the inherent problem though that
once you set this income and I'm not
asking you for the number that you're
giving everybody but once you set this
that just the way economics works I mean
you're just gonna increase the cost of
everything else for everybody right so
they've seen basic income studies and I
mean the evidence this week of course
like there's not been like a full-scale
like great you know ideal basic income
and forest but they're giving you a
basic water level thank you how are we
choked to death um but they're all still
be incentives to work and there will
still be positional goods and positional
advantages all of these that can come
sure do I think is give people the
freedom not to participate in the labor
economy right if they don't want to I
guess the thing that I struggle with is
that once you set it that you will
always have politicians coming in that
want more votes from the people that are
getting it and they're just always gonna
say raise it raise it raise it and that
every year that goes by we're just going
to raise it and raise it and raise it
and that will raise the cost of
everything else
like it that to me is the human part of
it yeah that I struggle with that it's
just nature every politician is gonna be
like well if I look at my district we
have a lot of people on it let's raise
it I want more votes yeah and so I don't
think that the basic income and this is
true of basic income advocates across
the political spectrum very few will
ever say that the basic can compete
should be raised so high that it
depresses the total pie you know so like
you wouldn't like the basic gave it to
be as high as it can up until the point
that it doesn't you know swing over each
in the other direction right but is that
just not the way politics works I think
that's that's sort of what I worry is
the problem that I get you
you know to me like I completely
understand that but just the nature of
the political system you're gonna give
them this this power to do this and then
always they will raise it and whatever
that threshold is that you're talking
about of course they're gonna run over
that yeah but that's gonna be true of
whatever your kind of political ideals
are is that you're always going to be
have to have a concern about these sorts
of public choice worries or like moral
incentives that are going to cloud
people's vision I'm interested in like
what does justice require like what's
the truth about what justice requires
and I think that a mistake that
libertarians often make is that they
they're sort of like question begging
and their arguments for having property
rights will just be like people have
rights to their property rights without
explaining why where those property
rights came from and I think that what
justice requires does include a respect
for certain kinds of property rights
whatever the kind of natural rights are
but that often times the enforcement of
a property system far exceeds that and
so as a matter of justice the basic
income could be a form of compensation
for that initial injustice so that's a
very in principled argument you're kind
of asking like oh but like in practice
what did that like right I'm just giving
you the rubber meets the road one like I
get it at the philosophical level for
sure but then so you might think like
what's the point of what's the point of
this defense the basic income if like in
practice it wouldn't mmm-hmm but you
always have to have some kind of ideals
about what you think is true about
justice just to ground like what are
your kind of North Stars for like what
policies you advocate for now and so
like where the rubber meets the road you
might think like is well now given that
we have this view how do we assess
existing policies here's one way to
think about this being informative think
about cash transfers as benchmarks for
any kind of assistance program so like I
think that cash is a more respectful way
to help people because it respects their
authority to decide how best to help
themselves or how to make choices that
reflect their own values and so you know
whatever intervention public officials
want to enforce on behalf of people in
order to help them out let's just hold
it up to a benchmark a per-person
benchmark of like how people could have
used use them
individually if you just sent them that
money as a check and like I think that
some programs will probably beat that
benchmark but just thinking in terms of
using a cash transfer as a benchmark for
evaluating the justice of different
things that public officials use
redistribute of Taxation to do that's
like one practical implication of
thinking about a basic income is being
required by justice yeah it's
interesting all right I want to finish
strong on critical thinking because it's
a phrase that I mention often on this
show that I think if we're lacking one
thing in this country more than any of
those it's critical thing and the
ability to think clearly look at a
problem understand your intellectual
opponents argument as opposed to just
what you think their argument is not
impugn everyone's motives I mean that's
basically what I've tried to do on the
show consistently for a couple of years
right now do you think we're like a
critical thinking disaster moment right
now like we don't see it we don't like
it just in the public course like well I
think in the public discourse maybe not
when you're with a lot of academics that
you're spending time with but I think
the general public discourse is really
lacks critical thinking it's like we've
picked our sides we're yelling at each
other all the time we're demonizing
constantly all of that we're not
thinking about issues really clearly and
critically more so than in the past do
you think I think partly the Internet
has has caused this you know the Twitter
a'f occation basically of everything and
the short way we think about things and
we go from one crisis to the next crisis
/ outraged about something one day and
then we forget it about it the next day
you know even if you look at the the
shooting in Las Vegas it's about two
months ago you know I think 58 people
dead it seems like there's almost no
information about it like we just let it
go we just forget things which i think
is a part of critical thinking like we
just don't look at things sort of
holistically and and try to figure out
what really is true yeah I mean you
might fall into like a sort of
availability bias where like you see
people on the internet shouting at each
other and being mean and people kind of
acting in bad faith or because they're
critical your like critical thinking
worse than ever then like look at the
past where which I think
the pass was by and large terrible place
yeah yeah I'm not saying it's worse than
ever there's something about it that
fuels perhaps because of the internet
worse but generally I just don't think
we're in a good state right now comes to
critical thinking but I mean what's your
counterfactual I mean cuz like like when
was it better yeah and though you might
look at the internet now I would guess
II would I would say was probably better
around our around the time of the
founding of the country that the
founding father is at least when they
were writing documents these were
principal documents that they were
having really you know lincoln-douglas
that's not founding times but a personal
thinker there yeah absolutely
Thomas Jefferson is my favorite founder
what are you since your favourite
founders yeah what what do you like
about Thomas Jefferson I love Thomas
Jefferson what do you I mean his
understanding of Liberty and liberalism
and what the role of government should
be I mean interesting that he was like
writing Declaration of Independence
while he is owning slaves and you're
right he was it was bad like I was not
good if you're gonna pick a favorite
founder I would not pick Germany George
Washington owned slaves too yeah and
didn't free them till his deathbed but
those are but that to me that just shows
that these were complex people of their
time yeah Thomas Jefferson you're right
he was writing the laws to free the
slaves while he owned slaves and I went
to his house in Monticello and they they
give a really I think very forthright
explanation of what his life was like
but I mean if you go to the Washington
Monument I was there just a couple weeks
ago and you really read the things that
he was writing about yeah he was a
flawed human but I mean there are things
that 50 years from now they're gonna
look back that we're probably saying
right that's exactly right yeah and I
think that is one of the values of
critical thinking is to try to look
around where we are now and be like okay
we know that in the past it was like a
moral catastrophe for women never heard
people of color the past was such a bad
place and very likely and people who
were really trying really trying to do
good critical thinking like picker
person I don't know that would take
Thomas Jefferson but he's not my
favorite founder
people were really good faith people
we're making really big moral mistakes
very likely we are living through a kind
of moral catastrophe right now but we
can't see it and so the value of
critical thinking is to say like what is
that moral catastrophe that's in our
midst right now and I think that there
are some candidates that people are
talking about and then there are some
things that we might not even be able to
imagine now is critical thinking
especially bad now because of the
internet maybe but maybe critical
thinking is getting better because of
the internet I kind of think like how
incredible that I have access to so much
of human knowledge just like sitting in
my office right so many more arguments
than I would have seen before like
before people sort of only knew the
perspectives of their own place and time
maybe what looks like it's the critical
disaster thinking disaster is just that
people are exposed to all of these
different arguments and perspectives and
that in the past they weren't and so
like yes there's more conflict but
there's also potentially more progress
yeah on the same dimension hello I
didn't know I sort of like took a turn
with that answer but like when you
mentioned that there were products at
that time maybe we are living through a
moral catastrophe there's a nice paper
about moral catastrophe that I think it
does illustrate the value of maybe both
critical thinking and a sort of
epistemic quick humility like that sort
of like a you wear also really getting
it wrong in this way yeah maybe we'll do
a whole other show on the founders
together and intellectual historian yeah
that's just really interesting to me and
obviously we don't have to end this in
perfect agreement on that but I think
it's it's interesting because to me
Thomas Jefferson everything I've ever
written his his thinking his thinking
was perfectly clear it doesn't mean that
the person yeah that he was it was not
flawed and by yes by 2017 standards we
know he was having sex with a slave
which in effect is rape because he had
the power over her so I I get it and yet
at the same time as I said it was
writing the laws to free them was doing
so much goodness for people to own their
lives and be individuals and
and you have the country that we have
right now and I just think it's yeah so
that's why I love him but then there
were also like abolitionists you know at
the time and throughout history who was
getting it right and so I mean I think
one thing that I think that when we
think about I think he was trying to
nurture the system through a horrible
phase basically you know what I mean
like yes there were abolitionists that
were more openly abolitionists than he
was as he was part of the government but
he was also trying to not destroy
everything at once because there was a
lot of goodness in the system - yeah I
did not expect enough yeah we in effect
critical thinking it's yeah maybe
there's maybe there's an internet piece
of it that makes it sort of better and
worse at the same time yeah I think that
one thing that sometimes happens in
these sorts of debates is a sort of like
relativism where people become like very
suspicious about like thinking about
moral truth or like they're being
immoral truth and I think like oh well
true for the time or true for that place
or true for that person and then there's
like this sort of like second step or
people are like so like who's to say
like you know something we'll just have
a sort of like we should all just be
tolerant of everybody else's few points
and like we should we shouldn't like
cast judgment on people with whom we
disagree in any tense and I think that's
true that you should have a sort of
robust tolerance just for people
expressing different kinds of few points
but I also think that that doesn't mean
that there's not like a right answer and
like there definitely are right answers
they're just really hard for us to know
and like sometimes when people disagree
or when people on the internet or like
oh like being mean to each other because
people think like the that sort of cast
out on like anybody being right about
anything if you want to be the person
who says that like people shouldn't be
mean but like no like I think that
there's like a truth about like the
right and wrong answer about these
questions about moral questions and
political questions about justice
about what we should do but that part of
that right answer is that we should have
more tolerance that we should be
tolerant of different viewpoints but
that's that's something that's a moral
claim to like we shouldn't have like a
kind of I think we should resist from we
should resist a move to relativism from
the view that like we should be
respectful of disagreement you know like
I'm completely different completely I'm
completely with you on that and I'm
always for more tolerance in the truest
sense of what tolerance is not not fake
tolerance that we that we often see
these days I think we should since
you're already co-authoring a book where
you're taking one side and another side
will do the the co-authored Thomas
Jefferson book there you go I'm just
planting it's been a pleasure chatting
with you and for more on Jessica follow
her on Twitter it's at miss Jessica
that's a great how did you get that
Twitter in that's a good one and check
out her book pharmaceutical freedom
[Music]
you
[Music]